we've all shed us here or to watching a
film though some of us may never admit
it if you're looking to let it all out
over some particularly poignant film
you've come to the right place bring
some tissues for your issues and beware
of spoilers as we take a look at some
movies short to make you cry The Iron
Giant this 1999 animated classic tells
the story of young Hogarth Hughes and
his metal eating buddy as they embark on
an exciting adventure in suburban Maine
in the late 1950s fueled by Cold War
paranoia the US military thinks the
gentle Iron Giant is a threat and
launches a nuclear missile Adam and
Hogarth's hometown the lovable hunk of
metal
minimally but effectively voiced by Vin
Diesel makes the ultimate sacrifice to
save the town and his new friends but
that alone won't make you blink back
tears here's the kicker having
previously bonded over Superman comics
with Hogarth The Iron Giant imagines
himself as the Man of Steel as he soars
through the sky moments before the new
compared him apart
[Music]
if the cartoons never made you cry this
could be your kryptonite guardians of
the galaxy 2014's magnificent addition
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
guardians of the galaxy earns a ton of
praise for its charming performances its
tongue-in-cheek take on the superhero
genre and its bangin soundtrack but it's
also a major tearjerker like the Iron
Giant before him giant tree dude groups
also minimally yet effectively voiced by
Vin Diesel sacrifices himself to save
his friends by covering them with an
unbreakable group spear but the tears
really start flowing when rocket asks
crew why he would give his life for
theirs prompting a poignant twist on the
big guy signature three word mantra who
knew trees had such big hearts and who
knew Vin Diesel acted better when you
gave him fewer words to say oh like the
brightly colored balloons lifting Carl's
house you probably saw this one coming
from a mile away up is notorious for its
unbelievably sad and sweet opening
sequence you go in expecting a quirky
tale of a cranky old man his floating
house and his chubby Boy Scout buddy and
then get socked into stomach with
sentiment 6r proved it's much more than
that twee tails right from the get-go
offering up a sprawling love story in
miniature as Carl meets Ellie the love
of his life and we get to see their
entire relationship play out up to
Ellie's death
[Music]
that's all in the first 10 minutes
thanks for making a cry into our popcorn
Pixar The Shawshank Redemption this
widely beloved 1994 flick is best known
for the relationship between convicts
Andy and red and Andy's elaborate
decades in the making escape plan but
it's the story of elderly convict Brooks
Hatlen released on parole after 50 years
behind bars that will have you clutching
the Kleenex despite his best efforts
Hatlen just can't adjust to life on the
outside I don't like it here I'm tired
of being afraid all the time I decided
not to stay Hatlen entire farewell
monologue is during an ugly cry inducing
scene ending in his suicide just before
he hangs himself in his apartment he
carves Brooks was here into the ceiling
beam Field of Dreams there is nothing
quite like a moving father-son scene but
it's made even more powerful in a film
like Field of Dreams
after receiving visions and hearing
voices in his head Iowa corn farmer ray
Kinsella constructs a baseball diamond
that magically draws in one very special
player ray is dead father John we won't
give away too much of the context but
the pain of Ray's journey to see his
father once more and to have him beam
with pride will reduce you to a puddle
of tears as with most films on our list
a single line will stab you right in the
chest
we have Church
[Applause]
I'd like that and cue the ugly man tears
the lego movie yes a movie about plastic
dudes battling an evil Will Ferrell is a
tearjerker and like Field of Dreams
it's all about daddy issues in an
unexpectedly moving twist the
imagination of a real-life boy sin is
revealed to be responsible for the brick
based hijinks of the animated story
Finn's father realizes his son's made-up
antagonist President business is
actually based on him his perfectionism
and his less than stellar parenting
skills
he asks Ben what his protagonist Emmett
would say to President business and the
response will punch you right in the
feeling you are the most talented most
interesting and most extraordinary
person in the universe the tears really
start to flow when Finn tells his father
you can change everything oh boy time to
call dad thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]